europa criminaliza los talibanes pero
decide blindarse ante las personas que
huyen de ellos tras dar por terminadas
las evacuaciones desde el aeropuerto de
kabul los ministros de interior de la
unión europea se reunieron este martes
para tomar medidas frente al esperado
flujo migratorio de personas queriendo
escapar de afganistán el objetivo de la
cumbre evitar que se repita la llamada
crisis migratoria de 2015 desatada por
la guerra de siria
a todo el mundo le gustaría evitar una
situación como la de 2015
y podemos evitar la estamos mucho mejor
preparados y podemos extender la mano
para hacer cosas desde ahora no no
deberíamos esperar para tener gente en
nuestras fronteras en 2015 la unión
europea optó por reforzar su política de
externalización de fronteras ante la
llegada de refugiados sirios que se
juntaron en las puertas de europa con
personas de decenas de nacionalidades
sin visados en 2016 bruselas firmó un
acuerdo con ankara por 6.000 millones de
euros el pacto fue ampliamente criticado
por defensores de los derechos humanos
que lo bautizaron como acuerdo de la a
la externalización de las fronteras
europeas implica a decenas de países que
como turquía usan el control de la
migración como punto de presión a las
instituciones comunitarias en 2021 la
línea de actuación es la misma
nuestra posición es proporcionar la
mejor ayuda humanitaria a las personas
que hayan decidido huir lo más cerca de
sus casas posible el cierre de las
fronteras exteriores europeas abre
peligrosas rutas migratorias
clandestinas según la organización
internacional de las migraciones más de
1300 personas murieron intentando cruzar
el mediterráneo solo en 2021 uno de los
ejes de legitimación de esta política
migratoria es el discurso de la amenaza
con el que se mezcla migración irregular
y seguridad una amalgama que atiza el
fuego de la xenofobia